[Music]
hey everybody it's monday i think in it
i never know what monday it is anymore i
mean i kind of do but you know money
i was up at the biker bar yeah he'd been
up at the bike in our lives pretty much
over there all afternoon yeah about
three and three and a half hours yeah
where did you leave
i don't remember one something yeah and
then he came back at like 5 30. yeah so
yeah four hours [ __ ] uh had megan spy
v up there [ __ ] posted a video of her
she was uh streaming to her
um
subscribers and making money and i was
being the cameraman and she's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] funny you know
she's just trying to make money
you know you know how it is aren't we
all yes
she's up there [ __ ] you know uh
shaking her booty and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
the bikers are laughing and i'm taking
i'm the cameraman
i'm cutting jokes she wants to come she
wants to come meet you she's [ __ ]
funny megan's funny she moved in here
she's she moved back
but uh
she's got a little 14 year old daughter
and stuff you know she's just she also
wants to go to mannequins and meet uh
tom big tom
because she because she's a dj
oh all right yeah she's a biker dj well
they do different nights there it's not
all yeah i mean it's got the new wave
like fridays and saturdays but the rest
of the time they do other [ __ ] she'd be
great because i was spinning there on
the d on on the uh
on the uh [ __ ] jukebox and she's like
you got good taste in music
hell yeah
and she was like i like everything you
spent but anyway yeah well there you go
right
i was showing her pictures to you and
she was oh she looks cool i got to meet
her she looks [ __ ] awesome and i was
like yeah you'd like you'd like jenny i
am quite awesome yeah
why do you say so myself yeah she's like
yeah she liked you she's like oh she
looks awesome
yeah
anyway all right
so let's talk about this movie
now this was actually one that you had
wanted to watch i saw it before like a
long long time ago but i couldn't
remember anything about it yeah i heard
about it and and uh it came highly
recommended because
it's kind of like where alien and
prometheus came from they were they were
copies of this movie sort of yeah kinda
and i saw it and uh
was impressed for 1965 this is the [ __ ]
i mean yeah this is playing into the
vampires right into the vampire so this
was directed by
mario bava which is one of jenny's
favorites yeah uh normally i don't think
he did any other sci-fi but uh this was
kind of like the his his take on sci-fi
planet of the vampires is not the
original title for this yeah and uh it
doesn't have anything to do with
vampires really not really they're
aliens it's a vampire-like product but
they are not vampires in any classical
structure yeah i think the i think the
[ __ ]
italian name was something like planet
of the dead or planet of the no it's
just called terror in space terror in
space that's what it was terror nello
spa terror in space space terror yeah
i got some space space terror so that's
like nice and generic yeah yeah but what
ended up happening was that
you know how
um
american international pictures
uh they had distributed some of mario
baba's other movies like earlier movies
like black sunday and black sabbath and
stuff like that and they'd had like a
lot of success with that so they were
kind of like well why don't we just sort
of like cut out the middleman and we'll
work together with the italian directors
to kind of co-produce things rather than
us like just having the finished movie
and releasing that you know what i mean
so this was actually their first like
collaboration
where they made the movie together and i
think there was like also a spanish
production company in there too
but now this movie
is
really low budget and it's really funny
like it has like it's mario baba so it
looks
fantastic yeah you don't have anything
like diallo in space you don't need
money to have a cool looking flick
the the flick looks really cool but it's
artistic it's not realistic
a lot of colors good costumes
um
you know it's kind of like something
you'd see the british were making in the
70s kind of you know like
journey to the center of the earth or
something you know i mean it's kind of
like along that that lines i liked it i
liked it but don't expect realism just
expect art
yeah i mean visually i think that's its
greatest strength yeah um it doesn't
have like a lot of characterization it
doesn't have a lot of you know it's a
little bit slow
um but
you know and like i said they're not
vampires so we'll get into that a little
bit but
um but just the visuals of it are so
[ __ ] awesome looking and knowing that
this was like uh an influence on alien
and slasher fred points out too that uh
it the terror from beyond space is
another old sci-fi movie that was also a
direct
uh influence on alien 2. now the thing
about it is that
ridley scott now after somebody pointed
out because people pointed out at the
time when alien came out like back in
1979 that hey this is like mario baba's
planet of the vampires like in some
aspects
ridley scott said he'd never seen it
which okay i can buy that dan o'bannon
the guy that wrote the screenplay
he also said i never saw that movie back
then but then later on he admitted yeah
i did i did see it and everyone's like
well obviously well and the interesting
thing about it too is that dan o'bannon
also wrote the screenplay for
life force toby hooper's life force from
1985
and that was also kind of about space
vampires that technically weren't really
vampires but like alien vampires so it's
kind of like so he must have totally
seen this they weren't really vampires
it's more like body snatchers yeah yeah
like a parasite that could get into a
dead body and reanimate it
that's essentially what they were so it
was more like i mean there were some
like vampiric aspects in the sense well
in what sense in one sense where like
they buried them and then like the
people came back and like pushed off the
thing so that's kind of vampirey but
they weren't like drinking blood or
nothing like that they were more like
like you said body snatchers were kind
of like symbiotes right type of thing
they were like uh disembodied souls that
could possess you and make you do things
and if you died they could get into your
body and reanimate your body
uh but they were just aliens
they weren't any kind of undead thing
but it was kind of neat they were coming
up out of the grave
yeah the corpses were getting back up
but they weren't the same people they
were possessed by and they would they
were intelligent they'd talk to you and
stuff
now um
the movie
i thought was great it had a lot of good
trick photography
they were trying to give scale to
certain shots like they'd have people in
the foreground and then you know like
[ __ ] ships in the background
uh good costumes
uh for 65 this this looked great
you know much better than star trek
uh you know like the star trek
television series a lot better than that
uh this is kind of like some people have
said that this is the best
italian science fiction movie
which it might be it might be i haven't
seen a great deal of italians but i'm
really into italian horror and giallo
movies but i haven't really seen i'm not
into sci-fi like hugely in general so i
haven't seen a lot of italians i would
put this at
at a similar level to forbidden planet
a lot like forbidden planet even though
for blood and planet was probably 10
years prior
quality was similar yeah it went for
bitcoin it can't come out 58 50s i think
i want to say it was 58.
totally wrong forbidden planet was cool
but that was like a glorified [ __ ]
star trek episode
but so is this
it's just the way science fiction was
this is much better than your average
science fiction
for the 50s and the 60s it was much yeah
i mean for 1965 like i said even just
the visuals alone are gorgeous and
knowing that
mario baba had essentially like a
[ __ ] nickel to work with yeah um it's
so funny like on the wikipedia page they
had like a quote from him and he's like
you know how we made the planet he's
like that entire planet is two plastic
rocks he's like one two two plastic
rocks he's like how we did it was they
put um and turn them around well they
put mirrors yeah like to reflect stuff
and he's like they just covered
everything in like super saturated
colored lights and fog and everything
like that so that a lot of it was
miniatures and stuff too which you can
see at the beginning like the ships yeah
especially
especially in high definition um you
know the ship at the beginning like
you're like it looks like a toy yeah but
that's okay though because the whole
thing is just like stylized and it's not
really meant to look realistic or
practical or theatrical yeah i mean
because even like the the space suits
that all the crew members wear are like
motorcycle leathers yeah it looks like
with big huge coffee collars
it was good for the time because then
they had other parts to that suit
like they had a helmet that went on and
it was flexible you know i mean where
they could look around instead of having
a big dome over their head like a lot of
the suits
of the time on the uh
in in movies the spacesuits i thought
were
futuristic
for the 1964 1965. they looked good
um
they also looked expensive they were
definitely leather
you know yeah they were like leather
jumps like you said it was like a
motorcycle motorcycle like something
that motorcycle racers would wear but
like real stylish because it's italian
yeah and some people be like well what
you know most
italy has always been known for
motorcycle leathers they have a lot of
[ __ ] companies that come from there
and
back in the 60s you had small
shops that would make motorcycle racing
suits you know to order for racers
and it looks like it was something that
came out of one of those motorcycle
racing shops but they look good they
look actually beautifully made yeah but
the first time like i saw the whole crew
wearing that i'm like they must be
sweating their balls
it's like it's not realistic but it is
stylish and the same thing with the
[ __ ] insides of the of the spaceship
back in the 50s an american in an
american spaceship interior was a black
and white room with uh some fake
computers with a bunch of lights
this one it was on par of say better
than
star trek uh uh the star trek [ __ ]
enterprise
uh
from the television series it was better
than that and it was dark it was like
kind of like a
haunted
a haunted they were trying to make it
look like everything was haunted yeah
they were trying to make trying to spook
you out
which is great you know what i mean
because that's kind of what alien was
trying to do everything was dark and
kind of wet and [ __ ] rusty and this
one no it was dark with blue lights or
green lights and round [ __ ] interest
ways and
it was just uh
they were just trying to put a different
mood than
than you would normally see back in
[ __ ] 65 for space
this is supposed to be kind of like
scary space
scary scary space and it worked hard
space
yeah you know for that time
it's a good flick
yeah this one oh you know what's
interesting too i didn't realize this uh
when we were watching it but
the this is actually based on a short
story like an italian short story but
the screenplay was written by good old
ib melchior i think that's how you
pronounce it and he also wrote the angry
red planet
and the time travelers which was
actually on the newer mst which is
actually not a bad movie and robinson
crusoe on mars and reptilicus which was
also
uh which is also on the new msc so he
wrote like i kind of feel like he wrote
a bunch of 50s sci-fi i think he was
wasn't he dutch or something like that i
think i looked him up before but i think
he wrote um
what was that one where the [ __ ]
uh
the mole people did he write them all
people i don't know but he might be like
wrote something like that but uh angry
red planet and time travelers robinson
crusoe mars reptilicus those are the
ones that he's like best known for
but so listen to what happens in this
movie and let me know if you think that
this uh that dan o'bannon totally saw
alien before now i'm willing to
concede that maybe because i've had this
happen to me before because i'm a writer
too
sometimes you see something like a movie
or whatever like a long time ago and you
don't really remember it but then like
later on you're like writing a story and
you're like oh hey i got this idea and
then you write it and then you re-watch
that movie you saw a long time and
you're like oh [ __ ] i just like ripped
that off but like you didn't remember
you didn't consciously like rip it off
you were just like
you know remembered it without
remembering it you know what i'm saying
but so this is what happens in this
movie
so there's two big ships right and
they're going into space and they get a
distress signal you know again from a
ship called aura now these two ships are
called the gallia and the r argos argus
yeah and uh so they start so they land
on the planet to see what the [ __ ] is
going on
now
when they now this part isn't like alien
but when they first land there like it
it gets like super gravitational like as
so everybody like starts smushing down
it's like super funny yeah they're just
like they're just like oh no they're
five g's it's five g yeah the science
makes no sense in the movie but science
never made sense in most of these i i
really do i like the scientific like
[ __ ] jargon in this one it really
entertained me it makes no sense i like
that what what's the red dish and every
red bean and 60 particles of megon like
instead of minutes or something like
that it wasn't for parcels of megan or
whatever it was yeah so i really liked
it it was kind of ruined the movie with
the pseudoscience they shouldn't have
done that but they didn't know what the
future would be like so they had to just
kind of make it up
but what was cool is that the ships did
look
neat for the sick from a 60s point of
view yeah kind of like manta rays with
jet engines on them yeah yeah something
like you'd see out of japanese
super robot comics you know like
something out of grand eyes or [ __ ]
you know neat [ __ ]
like i said a little [ __ ] pointed
[ __ ] manta ray looking thing with
[ __ ] jet engines and and the ships
looked like they i couldn't tell because
of all the like pretty mario baba
lighting but they looked like they were
blue yeah like with glowy
like i said i'm i'm a sucker for any of
that like super like saturated lighting
like um slasher fred brought up blood
and black lace yeah i just like i love
love that look
i love all that dario argento [ __ ] which
was inspired by mario bava i just love
the look of that um and if you don't
have a lot of money i mean lights are
cheap so you know you see we did the
colored light thing back there and i
love that and i just and i leave those
on all the time because i like the
atmosphere yeah but uh but yeah so
so afterward
uh you know after they all get smooshed
by the gravity then suddenly they kind
of start going nuts and trying to start
to kill each other
um
so there's that but then they finally
get there everybody like sorts
everything out and then they find the
other ship but there's like a bunch of
dead bodies in it
and so they end up burying them
and then
or they they bury some of them and then
they go back to get some of the other
ones but then they're like hey wasn't
bodies here and then they're gone
so
you know the plot thickens now the
interesting thing though and the one
thing i think that is the main thing
that you can take away like why this is
like alien is because one of the other
ships that they find which you're led to
believe is like an alien ship that
crashed here at some much earlier time
they go in there and there is a big huge
skeleton
of an alien being well there's several
there's one on the outside and there's
one inside and there's also one in the
door but you only see his hands yeah
right
it's a lot like an alien when they find
the engineers in the [ __ ] suit
it's pretty much exactly like right it's
pretty and you're wondering like well
are these the bad guys or whatever no
they were just some other suckers that
got [ __ ] called into this planet and
got killed yeah who were just like not
humans right yeah so later on you hear
recordings of their voices
yeah so that's almost exactly like alien
or prometheus because
yeah you get the whole thing where
that's like these big giant because we
were like yeah that's pretty much
exactly like alien
um and i don't know if that was in the
original short story because i haven't
read it it's in italian and i don't know
if there's an america that there's an
english uh translation of it but yeah
that's that was totally uh that was
totally that so yeah so then they find
out like they all start dying like
people die like they
start getting into fights and killing
each other off
and then they'll bury the bodies but
then the bodies get back up and start
walking around again so like i said
that's kind of where the vampire thing
comes from i guess because they do bury
them in the hole they put them in like
nice in a plastic bag like to keep them
fresh or whatever and then they they put
like this big metal slab
over them and then they do this big tall
metal doohickey which i guess is sort of
like a gravestone
but so there are a couple shots of like
the dudes like waking up and like
pushing the top of the tomb off which
but pretty much that's the only
vampire-like thing that's happening in
this movie but you don't really find out
until later that what is actually
happening is that like you said because
they do say oh we saw these flashing
lights and we couldn't tell what they
were people keep disappearing dead
people keep like getting back up and
walking around and then they find out
that what it is is these aliens are like
you said they're essentially like
disembodied souls or these little light
things that are floating around and they
need to get the [ __ ] off this planet
and so
they're like we keep having a distress
signal so you dumb asses can come here
and we can like possess your bodies and
then we could take your ships and [ __ ]
off
somewhere else star trek before
yeah that does sound very familiar i
mean this yeah and it's it'd be
interesting to know like who was
actually the first person that came up
with that plot because i do kind of feel
like that's been done a lot yeah like
aliens that are like oh help us help us
in the like yeah suckers we just needed
your ship right so we can get the [ __ ]
off remember the little [ __ ] annie's
gonna
sound like a [ __ ] buzzing going
around but then they slowed it down
there's people talking remember that
that's right which wasn't that the same
i think i feel like we just rewatched
like all the old star treks like
probably we watch we watch like the
whole series like once every couple of
years yeah you know what i mean
um mostly to see leonard namoy and
[ __ ] chat
well those two those two are [ __ ]
awesome right that's the best part yeah
oh hello they're gonna play [ __ ] star
trek the motion picture
had [ __ ] on the big screen yeah
yeah fathom events is doing it yeah i'll
have to look up when that is because i
actually i'd never got to see that on
the big screen actually i saw it i would
say it was great i wouldn't mind seeing
another victory yeah i like that fathom
events does that like they all because
we saw the shining that way we saw the
first the alien yeah uh you know so
that's like really cool that they do
that because there's a lot of stuff that
i didn't play the old [ __ ] man yeah
there's a lot of stuff like that i want
to see predator one on the big screen
again i'm sure they'll get around to it
i mean maybe you can it's well maybe i'm
gonna request it go to the fathom events
website and like see if there's maybe
they have like some polls or petitions
or something like that like for people
what they want to see and [ __ ]
or you'd i guess maybe if you'd have to
go around it like when an anniversary is
of that movie because i think that's why
they usually do it
um
but yeah
so
so yeah so basically you find out yeah
that these uh aliens and i
i kind of want to spoil the end because
like the end was like what like it had
this kind of big yeah it has some gotcha
and it has some gotcha endings i don't
think we should position somebody yeah i
think we should in case people want to
see it because it's uh we it's on for
free right
yeah we watched it on amazon prime
amazon prime for free yeah and that was
like this an angry red planet which is
the same writer not the same director
obviously but um but yeah those are both
on amazon prime for free
so and they're kind of similar
but
this one this one's better yeah this one
i think is better it looks better it's
like i said it's kind of slow like
because you can tell that it was low
budget and so they needed to like kind
of pad it out with like lots of shots
and people like walking around and [ __ ]
yeah but that that's kind of like that
happened with all the movies back there
there is some things about this movie
that makes it different though this is
an italian movie and you have cute
italian girls in there but there is any
gratuitous [ __ ] titty shots or
anything
so a bunch of guys were just like [ __ ]
that i'm not gonna watch it then yeah
no boobies yeah and uh
they're
um what's what is kind of good about
this movie is that the female characters
are not super screamy and fainty and
they're not there just to be
eye candy
they're they're actually our crew
members
which kind of reminds me of alien 2 and
aliens when
the crew members the female crew members
were just crew members
yeah i'm talking about i mean they're
really trying to to bring that across in
this movie that
they're just crew members they're not
here
to take their [ __ ] tops off basically
yeah they have the same uniforms as the
guys not even like star trek where it's
like oh the guys have like the normal
[ __ ] but you have to like wear a super
short skirt you know what i mean
even though it's like really impractical
it was genderism yes
yeah i mean
but this one everybody had the same
uniforms yeah and the women now there
was one woman when one of the guys like
got back like came back from the dead
the woman with the big blonde behind me
type thing she screamed and fainted um
but one uh yeah the dude was back from
the dead so i'll give her a pass and two
i think a dude fainted too at some point
so it's fine but i kind of like that
they didn't really make any like oh you
woman you know
they didn't do that kind of thing and
honestly they could all shoot they could
all do the same [ __ ] that the dudes
could i think it was it was trying to be
futuristic for the
465
to where there was like gender equality
into it
and i think that inspired them in alien
one and two to take that to the next
level where there are
female [ __ ] colonial marines and
their bad asses too and
uh the [ __ ] women are all kind of
just like the male
counterparts for the most part
there isn't anything [ __ ] high which
some people would go like well hey
that's not all that cool i mean people
have jet that's not what it it was just
they were just trying to make it more
realistic
that's the way life really is like you
know really it's more like that
um
it would just be a bunch of random
people trying to work
yeah more anything else you know
and that's kind of what this is i kind
of feel like i mean in alien i kind of
feel like all their roles were more
clearly delineated like what they did on
the ship
in this one it just kind of seems like
everyone's just like crew members you
know what i mean like one of the women i
think is a communications officer it
seems like from what her job is and
there's one guy on there who's a doctor
um but they don't really do a lot of
stuff having to do they're just kind of
there to get trying to change alive yeah
they're trying to did they get killed
and come back
from the dead
we kind of let we kind of laughed
because the doctor on there
is named uh dr karen
and so as soon as they said what is it's
k-a-r-a-n but i was like as soon as i
was like oh dr karen he wants to talk to
your supervisor so
there was that kind of [ __ ] too but we
did have a good time like watching this
it is um
like i said it's kind of slow but a lot
of movies back then kind of were but
honestly
you could put like some music behind
this it would make like a kick-ass i
mean just like every shot of it it's
just like gorgeous looking it's gorgeous
looking and hilariously just like a lot
of other italian movies and like a lot
of giallo movies if you watch a lot of
those
every single cast member in this i think
spoke a different language so everybody
just spoke their native language
and uh i think mario baba said yeah they
mostly didn't have a clue what they were
saying to each other and then they just
over dubbed it like later on so i think
there was like some italian speakers
some english speakers some portuguese
speakers some spanish speakers so it was
like everybody was like just saying
their own stuff so
you know so is that so everything's
dubbed but like i said that's kind of
like par for the course first john
gloria says i saw star trek the motion
picture in theater was like six it blew
my mind but i didn't really love it but
well you know yeah just i understand
what you're talking about
uh what you want to do is you want to
see uh star trek continues that's free
on youtube and it's a uh kind of like a
a fan series but it's it's like it's the
final
season of star trek the old series
redone by a new cast of the a lot of the
same writers from the old series
it's a great
final
season to star trek
and it kind of
if you if you see that last series of
star trek continues on [ __ ] youtube
and then you watch star trek the next
generation they bridged the two kind of
together
actually it would go into the movies
really but
um and star trek the motion picture
makes a lot more sense when you see the
final
season of star trek watch star trek
continues because it goes right into
that
about what happened to spock why did he
go back to [ __ ] vulcan
why you know why did all this [ __ ]
happen what was up with the [ __ ]
expert well you don't know about the s
burst because that's in that last one
but
um
no
uh
[ __ ] the guys from star trek
continues [ __ ] really made star trek
the motion picture a lot better
the the costumes the music and
everything that goes right into it
so i recommend that
but um the motion picture was good i've
seen it [ __ ] five or six seven times
i have it
it is good it's just that it was a
it was kind of a transition
because they were gonna make
a television series but instead that
they made that movie the television
series gonna be called
star trek phase two i think it was what
the name of the television series was
and a lot of the people that were gonna
be like the new captain and everything
or x almost kind of like extras in this
remember the guy who ended up being the
captain he had to stay with veger he was
going to be the new captain so
it's a lot more interesting when you
know the backstory
between that
because it would kind of have been cool
to have a whole series with that crew
yeah did you think yeah it would have
been kind of interesting but
no they decided to do movies instead
and they got rid of the crew
but you know you're back but that that
whole thing brought in [ __ ] the next
generation and the next star trek the
next generation was a great series real
good
even though and some of you
[ __ ] might say oh you're full
of [ __ ]
i actually liked [ __ ] star trek
[ __ ] um
enterprise with scott bakula and [ __ ]
jolene blaylock and everything that was
my the first cup first season and a half
kind of it was kind of slow but
once that [ __ ] started rolling i i
really liked that series better than
next generation
i kind of well i feel like i haven't
seen
i've seen some of next generation i've
seen all of enterprise because you liked
it so so i sat on i liked enterprise
but i don't know which one i liked i
still like the original one yeah i don't
i don't love any of the other ones as
much as i love next generation was good
um it took a while for it to find its
feet
it got kind of soapy after a while
but it was still pretty good and and
certain episodes really stood out from
next generation so it ranged from good
to really excellent
um but there's something about
next uh something about um [ __ ]
enterprise that i liked because they
didn't have they didn't have a lot of
technology the next generation they
could fix anything
they had so much techno jordy could fix
anything and that that was the problem
with it
uh but not in um enterprise an
enterprise they didn't have any
technology that's that's even before
captain kirk
is when
it was when the [ __ ] federation the
federation hadn't even started really
when um when when
the the federation hadn't started until
that series ended
it had a really good mirror episode that
explained what happened to the defiant
anyway i'm going off in a trek land [ __ ]
star
[Laughter]
i just can't keep you on one topic yeah
yeah yeah
john gore says i always mix up forbidden
planet with this island earth i do a
little bit too but uh yeah this island
earth i remember
more because that was like mst 3k in the
movie yeah the forbidden planet was a
lot better well yeah i know this island
earth was kind of this island earth is
good too but i don't i don't know i like
those [ __ ] i like those aliens with
the big [ __ ] brains brains
or is
on mst they call them uncle scroture but
because this head looked like a scrotum
um yeah lars ulrich said there was a
scary space movie from the 80s i think
with the vampires but with space
vampires i don't remember the title and
yeah john gore said life force yeah we
mentioned that earlier and like i said
that's the same writer dan o'bannon as
alien and alien was absolutely
uh inspired by my forces is [ __ ]
crazy we i really like slavery it was
good though yeah that's the one with the
naked chick walking up yeah you had a
hot
middle middle eastern european naked
chick walking around through the whole
[ __ ] move yeah she's a naked alien
being a [ __ ] she didn't need any damn
clothes
when you look like that you don't need
clothes
that's what they're paying you for well
yeah and they're just like and they
would go around like sucking everybody's
little [ __ ] essence out or whatever
and british soldiers are fighting them
with [ __ ]
[ __ ] styrog [ __ ] assault rifles
bullpups and [ __ ] they don't think it is
pretty good
yeah but yeah so uh if you're at all
into sci-fi or if you're all into alien
and you're kind of curious to see where
dan o'bannon maybe got some of the ideas
for the [ __ ] especially with like the
big skeletons for like the engineers and
stuff well it landed on alien planets
yeah fine and scary [ __ ]
yeah that's what it's about which like i
said that's not that's so general that
because a lot of 50 sci-fi had that too
but specifically those big skeletons
like finding that other alien yeah i
kind of feel like legs to the ships and
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's a lot i think that
was absolutely uh
like that yeah he definitely got the
idea for alien for that and yeah there
was another one called it the terror
from beyond space which also had some
aspects to it that uh that i don't want
to say alien ripped it off i'm just
saying it was in it was inspired by it
was an homage let's let's call it that
but uh yeah so if you're interested in
that then probably this one and it the
tara from beyond space should probably
see these as i said if you're into mario
bava and you really love his visual
style then this one is
you know again it's like a giallo in
space it's just basically like just
colored lights and fog and it's pretty
awesome but uh yeah so it's totally
worth watching so you know
that'll uh you you don't talk about it
yeah all right
yeah slash friend said there's an alien
rip-off called galaxy terror with robert
england galaxy yeah we i think we
reviewed that not too yeah yeah i like
generally i do as well that movie
actually is what uh brought all what's
his name into [ __ ] uh
it
brought him in the forefront and he came
up with alien too
and uh james cameron james cameron the
james cameron that did that movie
did all the [ __ ] that's awesome it also
had aaron moran in it from happy days
right and uh terminator one came from
that and
had a lady getting raped by a giant worm
yeah she was hot too pickle worm is
[ __ ]
rubbing kitties and [ __ ] slime and [ __ ]
and i'm [ __ ] a teenager and i'm going
oh yeah i wish i was that one
yeah
and that's what these movies was in
just some kind of generic [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] cultist badass and the [ __ ]
crystal i live for the crystals that's
right yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] jumped up
in his arm and went up to his it was
kind of like a alien rip-off and it was
so good that the guys that
[ __ ] wanted to do alien 2 hired him
to [ __ ] make it
okay
that galaxy of terror is like yeah it
was made as an alien ripoff but its
story is different enough and it's kind
of like a good movie in its own right
it's not as good as alien but it's still
pretty easy no it's not not a good alien
one but alien too [ __ ] you know that
he knocked it out of the damn park yeah
so galaxy terry was was fun man they
played it over and over on [ __ ] hbo
and cinemax and
we grew up watching it and [ __ ]
liking it
you know it was a creepy
space movie
yeah which i can't remember how long ago
we did a review of it probably like last
year i want to say yeah it wasn't that
long ago yeah i respect galaxy of terror
yeah it's good yeah all right so that'll
do it i guess for today
um i guess tomorrow we'll talk about
gone baby gone because uh louis sent us
that a while back and i'm i took me like
forever to watch it but i watched it
last night so we'll talk about it
tomorrow uh so yeah thanks for dropping
by today and we will see you guys again
tomorrow evening